over the past several years many of us
have learned how incredibly
life-threatening and dangerous viruses
and diseases can be they can cause any
number of critical symptoms and can shut
down your body's processes in a wide
variety of ways but there are more
diseases than just the ones we can name
off the top of our heads based on recent
experience many of these have nothing
anomalous about them despite being
incredibly strange take progeria it's a
genetic condition that causes people
carrying a very specific gene mutation
to age rapidly not twice as fast either
so fast that most victims tragically
don't live past their early teens or
elephantiasis if you're thinking that's
a disease affecting elephants you'd be
wrong but not grossly so
it causes the lymph nodes in your body
to stop draining fluid correctly so it
pulls up and makes your body parts swell
to a massive size until you look like an
elephant and of course there's the nasty
disease known more commonly as the bone
growth disease or the bone prison
syndrome when most people's muscle cells
die they get a nasty bruise but no
lasting damage but for people with this
rare genetic mutation dead muscle cells
ossify they turn into bone and muscle
cells die slowly anyway even if they're
not damaged in any way over the years
sufferers have had their body gradually
turn into solid bone all strange and
terrifying aren't they but none of them
are anomalies surprising as it may seem
they're all perfectly real diseases
documented by modern science you can
even search them up and see evidence if
you don't believe us but it begs the
question if these seemingly
logic-defying and impossible diseases
are just the ones known by modern
science then what kind of diseases break
our understanding of science physics
biology and chemistry so much that they
need to be categorized as anomalous and
of course contained by the foundation we
have a few examples the most notable of
which is scp-008
the fabled zombie plague exactly what it
sounds like on the tin but today we're
going to be looking at something else
entirely one of the many anomalous
biohazards that the foundation keeps in
cold storage deep below the surface of
the earth to ensure that they're never
to infect another human being again but
this one is a little unique when we talk
about dangerous diseases we always
consider the outcome the most danger a
disease could possibly pose to be deaf
however our topic for the day doesn't do
that frankly death might be preferable
to what it does to you
scp-2370 has a nickname around the
foundation's medical department they
call it the scarecrow virus that name
alone raises a lot of questions usually
diseases are named scientifically or
according to the symptoms they give to
anyone unlucky enough to be infected by
them but scarecrows aren't dangerous
they're not even alive the simple little
straw effigies that farmers stick in
their corn and wheat fields so that
crows don't pick their crops clean
before they can be harvested what do
scarecrows have to do with a biological
threat that the foundation has decided
is dangerous and anomalous enough that
it must be contained least the wider
world learn about it well i suppose the
only way to find out is by reading its
documentation which is honestly quite
sparse it's not the massive multi-page
goliaths that many entries can turn into
it's short it's simple and perhaps it's
better that way this is one of those
cases where the more details you get the
more disturbing the anomaly is but let's
get into it
scp-2376's object class is euclid which
is at least a good first sign it means
that it's not too hard to contain which
in the context of a disease means that
it's not amazingly communicative or
contagious that's good all things
considered
scp-008 and scp-610 by contrast are
incredibly communicative and that's part
of why they can be so hard for the
foundation to contain the special
containment procedures for
scp-2376 are a little odd in fact they
barely reference scp-2376
itself instead they mostly refer to
scp-2376-1
instances and how to care for them feed
them communicate with them and so on and
so forth they go into detail that
scp-2376-1 instances can't be fed
normally but by using an automated
feeding system to limit human exposure
to them but they still need meticulous
care they have to be examined at least
once every eight hours by foundation
medical staff and the discomfort that
comes as a result of their infections is
to be alleviated as much as possible
while precise they're not exactly
surprising we know it's a disease so it
makes sense that these
scp-2376-1 instances are the victims of
the disease and as they're severely ill
they need to be fed and examined without
making their condition whatever it is
even worse or spreading it to staff but
they go on and they get stranger
scp-2376-1 instances can't actually be
informed or made aware of the fact that
the diseases they're suffering from as
cp 2372
is anomalous for some reason they cannot
be told about the anomalous properties
of it a text-based communicator for the
disabled kind of like the computer voice
system used by stephen hawking has to be
used to communicate with the instances
but personnel can't just wait for them
to type something out they have to close
and reopen their eyes every five minutes
to see if they've typed anything out for
some reason either victims of
scp-2376 can't move when they're being
looked at like the infamous scp-173 or
that people can't sense that victims
have moved until they close and reopen
their eyes either way very anomalous not
to mention the fact that they won't or
can't speak the next line is a very hard
very firm rule though not just a
directive for care under absolutely no
circumstances are patients to be removed
from their rooms or disposed of no
removing from rooms makes sense you
don't want the disease to spread and
cross-contaminate with the various other
anomalies the foundation site has in its
halls who knows what kind of superbug
you might wind up with but disposal is a
different matter the foundation isn't
allowed to get rid of victims of this
disease that seems obvious the
foundation doesn't kill people if at all
avoidable clearly something else is at
play here the next line gives a hint
personnel have to follow any
instructions given to them while
treating instances and have to be
regularly reminded that they're treating
a human being whatever this disease does
to people it causes others to not
recognize them as human and may
accidentally dispose of them all the
instances slash victims as well as
samples of the disease itself are
located at site 234 and mtf beta 7 the
mass hatters are to regularly
investigate hospitals in the area with
prior infection for repeat instances
beta 7 is a mobile task force trained
and equipped specifically to deal with
contagious or infectious anomalies a
cross between soldiers and doctors
scp-2376
is a sub-strain of the real-world
tetanus virus which is often called
lockjaw most people get a tetanus shot
in childhood that protects them from the
disease with regular booster shots so
they never have to suffer through the
grisly infection that's often found on
rusty metal lockjaw is called that
because the bacteria infects your
muscles and makes them violently spasm
locking your jaw muscles into a closed
position
there's no cure and about 10 percent of
cases are fatal but the scarecrow virus
is different while tetanus is found on
rusty nails
scp-2376 is zoonotic it's communicated
and carried by animals specifically the
common crow that sheds some light on the
name while it's carried by crows it's
transmissible to humans too as we
guessed the unfortunate victims are
designated
scp-2376-1 instances by the foundation
scp-2376's infection of humans consists
of two distinct stages stage 1 and stage
2. stage 1 is of course first and at
first seems mild it lasts between 1 and
4 weeks and has all the symptoms of the
regular tetanus virus like a fever
spasms and loss of mobility but with
some extra ones people also develop a
reddish rash across their body a cough
and vertigo they become afraid of
heights that would be strange enough but
it also affects the senses victims who
haven't progressed to stage two yet
complain about always smelling the odor
of straw corn and other materials you'd
find on a farm even when they're nowhere
near any farm they say that everything
they touch has a strange sort of film or
texture on it like rough burlap the kind
that you'd find a bag of potatoes to be
made of this is all certainly strange
but it's not something that you'd think
must be contained by the foundation just
an odd variant of the tetanus virus but
stage two is when things really get
complicated the anomalous properties of
the disease become readily apparent
after the victim progresses to stage two
they stop being perceived as human
anyone who looks at them only sees a
regular unmoving inanimate scarecrow
it's not that they become a scarecrow
either just that people can no longer
perceive them as anything but which is
arguably worse observers don't realize
that the person they were looking at
just a moment ago is suddenly gone or
has been replaced by a scarecrow to them
everything seems normal they don't
realize or question that anything's
wrong in fact they can't even perceive
any noises an
scp-2376-1 instance makes like yelling
or calling for help that's why they have
to use the text communication but why
the five-minute delay because people
can't perceive any motion by
scp-2376-1 instances either at least not
while looking at them if one runs across
the room right in front of an observer
they won't realize it and we'll see the
scarecrow still sitting where it started
but if they look away by turning around
or closing their eyes before making
visual contact with it again the
scarecrow will be in the position where
the
scp-2376-1 instance stopped moving the
disease doesn't just affect the person
who has it once stage two sets in it
affects people who don't have it and
have no exposure to it besides looking
at a victim that's why it's anomalous it
manages to change how people's nervous
systems and senses act while never even
infecting them
scp-2376 can't infect microphones or
motion detectors either though any
sounds made will still be picked up in a
sound recording and anyone tripping a
motion detector alarm will have its
sound immediately that makes containment
a little easier now that the foundation
can depend on at least physics and sound
but then you'd think a picture or
photograph of an scp-2376-1
instance would look like a normal person
right albeit bedridden with a rash and
spasming but a human being you'd be
wrong and same about videos visual media
just renders the victims as what they
appear to the naked eye a regular
harmless scarecrow there is one way to
stop the effect that
scp-2376 has on perceiving its victims
but it's not pretty when a victim dies
of the infection they can be perceived
as a human again though of course by
then it is far too late thankfully being
infected by scp-2376
isn't a death sentence the parts and
symptoms of the disease are shared with
regular tetanus can be alleviated with
the same treatments and remedies though
they can't be fully cured and even if
all the other symptoms go away the
largest and most anomalous aspect the
effect on others perceptions stays as of
testing so far there's no way to get rid
of that aspect of the disease except of
course death and the foundation has
performed extensive testing with samples
of scp-2376
murine models they infected lab rats
with the disease to see if the reaction
was the same as humans and how it
compared to lab rats with tetanus the
answer was extremely similar just like
tetanus if an
scp-2376-1 instance was pregnant when
they were infected the disease would
easily transfer to the fetus and give
the baby the scarecrow virus from birth
and rats that went to stage two also
were perceived as scarecrows tiny little
straw stuffed scarecrows shaped like
mice and stuffed with denim and straw
but unlike humans rats and mice eat
straw which is exactly what the
non-infected rats began to do to the
infected ones they were unable to
perceive the rat's cries or thrashing
and cannibalized it but
scp-2376 and tetanus are bacterial
infections by eating the infected rats
the other rats also became infected
showing the disturbed foundation
researchers how this disease managed to
spread unnoticed protocols were
immediately implemented to make sure
rats and mice couldn't get into the
containment chambers of scp-2376-1
instances plus they try to start eating
them and spread the disease like
wildfire through site 234 until the
medical researchers can get a better
understanding of what exactly
scp-2376 is and how it affects other
mammals besides crows people and mice
testing is ordered to continue and
several other researchers have noted how
similar the effects of the virus are to
other anomalies such as
scp-2316 a pathogen that causes the
entire body to lock up and stop doing
everything and scp-2218
a number of teleporting intelligence
scarecrows maybe
scp-2376 is the result of these two
anomalies coming into contact and
interacting as some of the researchers
are investigating or maybe it's much
more nefarious perhaps these anomalies
share a common synthetic origin like
someone trying to create an anomalous
biological weapon or maybe it really is
just a coincidence
scp-2376 was first encountered by the
foundation in the exact place anyone
would expect to find straw and
scarecrows the wide vast cornfields of
iowa in the united states but they
didn't find them in a field of wheat or
in a barn they found them where you'd
expect to find disease victims a
hospital more specifically foundation
agents found a number of corpses stuffed
into the garbage disposal units of the
hospital of a small iowa town the nurses
and janitors at the hospital had no idea
what happened they said that some
teenagers had broken in during the night
and dressed a number of scarecrows and
scrubs before leaving them in the wards
as a prank the staff in the morning had
found and disposed of them in the trash
knowing what we know about scp-2376
the actual story is much more tragic
somehow the infection had probably
gotten into a human at the hospital and
the doctors began treating it the same
as they would tetanus the doctors and
nurses had also got infected and quickly
entered into stage two while at work but
remember victims stop being perceived as
scarecrows when they die which means
that when hospital staff threw them into
the trash they were still alive if you
can call that alive but their thrashing
and yelling couldn't be perceived by the
others once they went into the disposal
units they quickly deteriorated and died
a deeply tragic situation all around but
how did
scp-2376 get to the hospital where did
it even come from foundation agents have
a pretty solid theory they scoured the
local town for any strange events
incidents or rumors about scarecrows and
found something much bigger than what
they were expecting a week before the
corpses in the hospital were discovered
a man in the next town over had died or
more accurately he had been killed his
wife called 9-1-1 incoherent and sobbing
and explained to the operator that she
found a spare scarecrow in the garage a
week before and had nailed it up outside
of the house on a post after three days
she had walked outside and found instead
of the scarecrow the body of her husband
at which point she broke down and called
9-1-1 the woman was tried for murder but
acquitted on an insanity plea based on
her claims of her husband having turned
into a scarecrow the man's corpse was
sent to the morgue at the hospital for
an autopsy which is probably how the
infection spread to the other hospital
staff but not before the autopsy was
completed and a report filed indicating
cause of death dehydration from being
out in the hot sun for three days
foundation staff quickly moved in and
quarantined the body confirmed the
presence of
scp-2376 in the blood and the wife
confirmed her husband had symptoms
similar to tetanus a few weeks ago as
for how the infection got into the man
that remains a mystery the outbreak was
considered contained by the foundation
and since then there have been only
cases here and there throughout the
american midwest until now an addendum
to the file indicates that the
foundation has located and identified a
new strain of scp-2376
the key difference being the carrier and
the effect rather than crows it is
transmitted by pigeons and its origin
point is in the highly urban location in
illinois more likely than not it's in
the third largest city in the united
states chicago and the second difference
is that instead of scarecrows the
infected are perceived as inanimate
mannequins the kind you'd see in any
clothing or department store based off
the vastly increased risk for the
epidemic the foundation's medical
department have requested that
scp-2376 be reclassified to ketter
scp-2376 goes to show how even the
diseases we don't know exist can be
dangerous in more ways than just
threatening our lives so next time you
see a crow scavenging for food in your
front lawn maybe think twice about
getting too close to scared away you
might just wind up on a pole in the same
front yard scaring crows away in your
new straw stuffed overalls forever now
go check out
scp-1025 encyclopedia of common diseases
and scp-610 the flesh that hates for
more on anomalous diseases that will
leave you crawling in your skin